am I under arrest or something
should you be
for someone who's not a drinker Jules
makes a real go of it after her failed
attempt to follow George's Clues into
the water at the end of the last episode
Walker will identify this response as
her wanting to run away which is
something that is easier said than done
when you live in a sealed structure that
is completely Underground episode 3 does
an excellent job of giving us more
information about who the mechanic
dangling at the end of this rope is and
introducing the politics of her world as
far as we can tell becoming Sheriff
isn't that much different than going
into the water but it might be running
in the direction of finding answers
about what happened to George I didn't
mention it at the end of my last video
but the closing shot was an effective
way to establish how someone who was
born in The Silo experiences things
Juliet is terrified of this water
because she's never experienced anything
like it we don't know how long they've
been there EX exactly but it's at least
140 years which means multiple
Generations have lived without ever
seeing a body of water or anything else
on the surface I did mention that
everyone sort of operates as if theirs
is the most important job in The Silo
and this episode really drove that idea
home when Shirley comes to wake her up
because Jules hangover has her still in
bed the room starts to shake from the
unstable generator the immediate threat
from this type of failure makes Jules
statement that hers is in fact the most
important job in The Silo have some
Credence but as is often the case and
especially in this setting everything is
connected so she can't just exist hyper
focusing on this machine in a vacuum
when she gets there to try to fix it she
gets upset seeing her Apprentice trying
to do her job I should mention that
everyone who works in The Silo has one
of these people their assigned to train
which are called Shadows this is
important because it's one thing to
punch a co-worker which we see Jules do
here but this is much more abusive given
the fact that his future employment and
essentially his quality of life is
dependent on this relationship two
things are established in this sequence
and the one that follows where she's
talking to her boss Knox Jules has some
issues Beyond her obvious grief related
to George's death she is a character
with flaws and I'm not overlooking this
in relation to what she does to Cooper
but the way she's protective of the
generator ties into the title of the
episode in some ways she's a person that
prefers machines over people which is an
idea that will come back to while this
is all happening mayor Johns and Deputy
Marne start their trip to the down deep
and we see them stop in front of
judicial for a drink of water as they're
talking the deputy points out that this
is more about not being seen by the
people who are standing outside this
helps to establish the politics between
the different factions that hold power
when they make it to I.T they do stop in
to visit Bernard the head of that
department who we met as Allison's boss
in the first episode from what we've
seen the role of I.T is still somewhat
mysterious but in relation to the
internal politics of The Silo you get
the sense that they're important the
mayor brings him a gift of Brandy to try
to carry some favor in relation to
naming the next sheriff and he mentions
running the numbers in relation to
holston's replacement judicial has its
own candidate that they want to put into
the position and when the mayor mentions
holston's pick of Juliet Bernard calls
her a thief he accuses her of stealing
four boxes of h-57 tape that were
reserved for it which he says they use
to prevent their servers from cooking
the details surrounding this seem like
they might be important otherwise it's
seems a little bit Petty but he
emphasizes that it doesn't matter what
she took it just matters that she stole
and in his opinion that disqualifies her
the mayor doesn't like the idea of
having judicials pick shoved down her
throat and it doesn't look like she
appreciates Bernard's advice to leave
Walking The Silo to kids with nothing
better to do both Bernard and later Sims
bring up the idea she needs to push
through their pick to maintain the order
of things they emphasize that time is of
the essence because the frightened
citizens have begun to arm themselves
which we saw a little bit of in the
previous episode the other stop they
make is the sea Juliet's dad Dr Pete
Nichols in the Maternity Ward we learned
that they haven't been in touch for a
while that she was not born in the down
deep she was actually born in the mids
and that her moving to Mechanical was a
choice she made when she was 13 years
old he doesn't get into details about
what happened but mentions a loss like
that and that she showed real interest
in machines from an early age the whole
encounter is a little bit uncomfortable
and a little bit hard to read and John's
just comes out and says that it brings
up more questions than answers but for
us it adds a lot of context for the
decisions that we see Jewels make I
think the most important thing he says
is that he thought it felt good for her
to be able to fix something the idea of
being able to figure out how something
works like the watch she got from George
or the generator and to fix them if they
didn't you can see how that was
imprinted from this event in her past
and how that ties in with the idea of
her preferring machines over people when
John's and Martin's make it to the 144th
level they're surprised to experience
that same shaking effect from the
generator whatever Jules has been doing
to fix it is failing and watching her
work impresses the mayor enough that she
decides decides to go visit her old
friend Walker to ask about her walker
isn't surprised to see that the mayor is
in the down deep because she can hear
what's going on with her illegal radio
John's looks the other way on that
because they have this relationship but
the idea that some tech is prohibited
for the population is something to keep
in mind you don't get to see what she
tells her but when John's comes back to
offer Jules the job she tells her that
she's the only other person in The Silo
who wants her to be Sheriff without much
thought she declines because she can't
imagine that anyone can be trusted to do
her job though after they leave Deputy
Hank notices something is carved on the
back of holston's badge and you don't
get to see what it says but you realize
that this is the sign he told Jules to
look for that makes her decide to agree
to take the job under one condition she
needs to fix the generator first and in
order to do that they have to shut it
down earlier Knox dismissed this idea
because it's basically never happened
and John's brings up the same thing but
her concerns are mostly because it will
lead people in the dark still they agree
and then we find out when mechanical
meets that they're not even sure if what
Juliet wants to do is possible I won't
get into the specifics other than to say
this is a version of a steam turbine and
it might seem strange that Shirley says
no one knows where the steam comes from
but keep in mind that asking questions
about things you don't understand can
get you sent outside to clean it goes
back to perspective and how you just
accept some things as truths if they're
presented to you that way steam comes
from the ground and there is a safety
built into the system that will allow
them to close the valve to stop the
generator this will only afford them a
small window of time to complete the
repairs and that sets up a very tense
and thrilling situation to watch Knox
and the others discuss how hard this is
going to be to pull off and the stakes
involved and I think that it's an
interesting setup because Jules isn't
wrong for as long as she's been working
on it the generator has continued to get
worse and it does need to be fixed but
this is only happening this way right
now because she told them what needed to
be done while leaving out that she
didn't really know how to do it it draws
attention to the fact that she has two
clear motivations to keep the generator
running and to figure out what happened
to George beyond that the details the
politics the people around her all of
these things sort of take a back seat
things go wrong when the temperature
increases faster than expected this
leads to Jules leaving Cooper behind to
do the job while she comes up with a
dangerous plan that might cool things
down long enough for them to finish she
uses a hose to spray the main valve
which works but it also means she has to
confront her fear of water when she
almost drowns her Shadow is able to get
the repaired blade back in place in time
they're able to get her back out of the
water Knox is able to vent the valve and
the generator fires up so they did fix
it the lights come back on and everyone
in mechanical breaks out in a
celebration in the middle of that
jules's look changes from excitement to
an empty stair which sets her apart from
this family that she's built up around
herself in the down deep and it's a
reflection of the fact that she's going
to be leaving them behind she stops to
apologize to Walker on the way out she
freaked out on her a little bit before
and threw it in her face that she never
leaves that apartment slash Workshop
that she's in they do make up and she
leaves George's camcorder with her
asking her to try to figure out what it
is as she leaves Walker tells her not to
end up like he did he died looking for
answers and then before she starts to
climb this stairs she flips over the
badge so we can see what Holston carved
in it when they were arguing in George's
hiding place he said the job of the
sheriff was to maintain order while she
said it was to find the truth and that's
what he put on the back of the badge
that he wanted her to have throughout
their trip we'd had hints that John's
and Mars had feelings that went beyond
their professional relationship and on
the way back up we see them Express
those to each other and even share a
kiss we also saw that Bernard was angry
with her decision to make Juliet Sheriff
but when she gets back to her office she
does make that official and tells Mars
to grab a bottle of wine and get ready
to go to her apartment she never makes
it though because you could see that
there was something going on with her
when she was signing the paper she
wasn't feeling well and when she goes to
the bathroom she collapses on the floor
there's something coming out of her
mouth it almost looks like she was
frothing marns is able to break down the
door to see what happened but the the
episode ends there I thought this was
another strong episode and as someone
who read the book I liked seeing the
choices they made to develop the
characters there's a very concentrated
effort that you can see if you know
where they end up and it should be fun
for people to put that all together
later because this is one of those
stories that reveals things in a way
that's like peeling off layers as far as
changes the whole shutting down of the
generator scene was completely different
in the book it just sort of happens
there's not much fanfare and they move
on what they went with works a lot
better for TV because otherwise it would
just be Jules planning things out and
this was you know edge of your seat
can't wait to see what happened and it
provided more information about what
kind of character she is judicial is
also something that they've added or I
guess expanded on from the books there
are at least a couple of mentions of
Judges but none of these agents are out
in The Silo doing things for their
political influence without giving away
any spoilers I think I know what they're
doing here it doesn't seem like a bad
idea I don't think it really changes
much so we'll see how it plays out
something that did feel like a surprise
if not a big change was the way the
screen in the cafeteria glitched when
they turned the power off and it showed
the Lush landscape that Allison
discovered on George's computer as
mentioned they do shut the generator
down in the book but I don't think there
was much made about it being completely
dark and this particular scene does not
happen I went looking online to see what
people were saying because I mean I know
what's going to happen and I know what's
going on outside and everything else so
I figured this would probably catch
people's attention and then I was a
little surprised because when I watched
the scene I read it as everyone there
that was sitting in the cafeteria was
worried about the lights going off and I
didn't see any reaction to What flashed
on the screen at all like I thought it
was mostly for us and it didn't really
affect what was happening with the
characters in that moment reading other
people's reaction it seemed like they
thought that some of those people did
notice and that that might lead
somewhere I'll just say if that's what
the show was going for I think they
could have done a better job of making
it clear either way the most popular
theory is that it was a flash of what
the outside really looks like which I
also saw a good counter argument for
from people who are just watching the
show and haven't read the book about how
the fact that it's daytime is suspicious
because obviously they turned the power
off at night when people would be
sleeping so that it would cause less of
a disruption for that eight hours it
might not be super clear yet but Holston
did say that he would go through the
cafeteria Before Dawn and after dark so
he didn't have to see Allison's body on
the screen when he went through there so
they do see time outside reflecting
their day and night cycles inside
there's also some debate about the
bodies not being there in the sunny
image but Holston didn't see them
through his visor when he was out there
cleaning either so I'm not sure why
people find that surprising there's a
possibility that this is hinting that
the show will go in a different
direction than the book did at least as
far as the way it reveals some things
because this is a choice that they
decided to make but I guess I'm not that
convinced at this point so we'll have to
wait and see as I said last week most of
the changes seem like improvements maybe
the one exception is judicial but I feel
like that's more of a neutral change
rather than something that makes things
worse I think we see some payoff from
adding the scenes with Holston and Jules
already it makes you wonder what he was
doing before he went outside and what he
might have left behind for her I thought
Will Patton and Geraldine James did a
great job of selling the romance between
marns and John's which gave what
happened to her some weight it
definitely makes the character of the
Deputy more compelling and makes his
reaction to what happened matter it's
also great how when you see Tim Robbins
in the first episode you think they
wouldn't have hired this guy for an
insignificant role but then he just sort
of Fades into the background for a while
the smile he delivers at the end of his
conversation with Johns was a master
class and how to say one thing with your
expression while conveying something
totally different with your presence and
it was cool to see Ian Glenn AKA sir
Jorah in something new and I'm not sure
how much I love his accent or Rebecca
Ferguson's for that matter but it's
still interesting because they're
obviously asking these actors to adopt
an American accent which is a choice
things are looking good the Mysteries
are there did George commit suicide what
happened to Mayor John's what made Jules
leave home at 13 to work in the down
deep and of course what's going on with
the silo anyways I think that seems like
a pretty good place to leave things
please like this video If you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon